hi Matt here thanks for listening to
think fast talk smart the podcast in
honor of our upcoming 75th episode we'll
be recording two free live events on
January 12 2023 I'll discuss three
critical communication tools we all
should hone and practice and then I'll
take your questions to sign up please
visit
stanford.io forward slash live 75.
that's
stanford.io slash live 75. we hope you
can join us January 12th for some fun
some learning and some prizes
at the end of the day communication is
all about connection
connecting our ideas
connecting to other people connecting to
a higher purpose like an organization's
Mission or vision
but how do we do this connecting
mostly it's through conversation
join me today as I have a conversation
about conversations
my name is Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
[Music]
I am super excited today to speak with
Allison wood Brooks Allison is the
O'Brien associate professor of Business
Administration and Hellman faculty
fellow at Harvard Business School
Allison's research focuses on the
science of conversation and interaction
and she teaches an award-winning course
called Talk
welcome Allison I am so excited that
we're actually getting to do this
it is awesome and I can't wait to get
into our conversation so let's go ahead
and get started I first came to know you
and your work when I was writing my book
speaking up without freaking out I came
across your research on reframing
anxiety I know it's from a long while
back but I'd love to have you share this
really helpful speaking anxiety
management technique do you mind sharing
of course I would love to so when I was
in grad school my dissertation was about
anxiety and everybody feels anxious and
not everybody needs therapy or
medication or that level of treatment
right and what you really need are just
sort of these smaller scale coping
strategies to help us deal with the very
normal feelings of anxiety that we all
feel a lot of the time so Matt what
makes you feel nervous does anything
make you feel nervous well I still get
nervous you know Allison it's funny I
get most nervous when I speak in front
of folks like you people who study
communication people who know what I
know know a lot more than I know that's
when I get nervous other times I've
learned to manage anxiety through
techniques like you're going to
introduce and others but I still get
nervous I how about you do you get
nervous too oh my gosh totally yeah and
I think we need to actually that was a
very you you put a compliment in there
so thank you that was very nice I think
I think we'll feel anxious not only when
we talk to
talk to him there's uncertainty and any
sort of lack of control which
conversation is that's sort of how it's
built right like we're co-constructing
this interaction right now I don't know
what you're gonna say I don't know what
you're thinking and I can't possibly
know so that uncertainty is always there
and lack of control is there because I
can't control how you react to me or
what you think of me so really
conversation is a very understandable
place where you would feel anxious there
are lots of other tasks that make us
feel anxious as well so we tried a very
simple coping strategy a very simple
intervention and the question was can
people reframe their anxious feelings as
excitement and it's a really simple idea
but the reason that it works is because
when we feel anxious we have this crazy
Instinct that we should try and calm
down
like really powerful everybody feels
like they should calm down when they're
anxious and that's hard right that that
would require that we mitigate the
physiological signs of anxiety so you're
racing heart sweaty Palms biked cortisol
in your body you're trying to like push
those down as well as move from the
negative valence right like a negative
emotion like anxiety and move into the
positive zone of calmness and that
two-step move reducing the physiological
signals and moving from negative to
positive it's pretty much impossible
it's very very hard especially the
physiological component of it so instead
what reframing as excitement does is it
allows you to stay in that high arousal
Zone you're not trying to combat your
automatic physiological processes but
instead you're just doing this mental
reframe from negative to positive I love
that it's so simple and in fact it
really is you just say hey these
feelings I'm having could represent
excitement and and then you can begin
thinking about what is exciting in this
opportunity I'm excited to share my
information I'm excited to contribute to
this conversation and that allows you to
move away from fighting yourself to calm
down to not be nervous and and I have
found this very helpful for myself and
in the students I teach and the people I
coach so I really appreciate not only
you explaining it now but for just doing
the work originally oh thanks Matt I'm
oh it's great well talking about talk we
teach one of the most popular electives
at Harvard's business school and it's
called talk can you tell us what the
premise of your class is and highlight
maybe one or two key takeaways
yeah I love teaching this course talk is
an acronym it's t-a-l-k and it stands
for topics asking levity and kindness
and what the course aspires to do is
help people talk just a little bit
better I started out in the business
school at Harvard teaching negotiation I
started to get a little frustrated is we
have such a focus both as scientists and
in public discourse on difficult
conversations or so-called difficult
conversations and this conjures
conversations like negotiations or
delivering constructive feedback or
giving hard advice or right these things
that we come to think of as difficult
what I've realized through my life and
teaching and through my research is that
even easy conversations are difficult
like we don't just suck at the hard ones
we suck at the easy ones too they can be
so stressful useful yes yes and and once
you delve into the complexity and the
Nuance that lives and breathes within
each conversation you start to see why
it's hard even even when our goals align
even when our only goal is to have fun
even that can be sort of hard right like
we might say the wrong thing we don't
know how our other people other people
are feeling what they're thinking about
and so that's what that's sort of the
humble and extremely ambitious promise
of the course let's make each
conversation just a little bit better
but in accumulation over all the
conversations of your life that can make
a massive difference for you and your
career and for the people you love I
have as you well know I've spent a lot
of time recently talking about these
spontaneous moments of communication
because a lot of what's taught in your
institution at my institution is how to
do formal planned communicating and this
notion of most of what we do in business
and our personal lives happens in the
moment and happens in conversation and I
love that you are studying it anyone
who's listened to this podcast knows
that I'm a huge fan of structure and
communication I think it can really help
us in many ways and I know you think a
lot about structure as well can you
share your thoughts and research in the
structure of conversations and how we
can better leverage this knowledge to
improve those conversations yeah of
course I would love to when I hear the
word structure it triggers so very many
ideas and and thoughts for me that I
actually wanted to turn this one around
on you Matt and ask you when you think
of the word structure especially in the
context of communication what types of
things are you thinking about great
question for me a structure is nothing
more than a logical connection of ideas
it's a bridging of ideas it and not only
is it the form that the communication
takes but it is the way you think about
the communication so having a structure
helps solve one of the two fundamental
problems I believe we have in
communication what to say and how to say
it what does your research tell us about
structure in my research I'm really
interested in topics and so what topics
are is you take a chunk of turns so you
ask me this question what do you think
about structure
and so turns our one organizing
structure so we can chunk the turns that
we've taken on this topic into a topic
and that opens up all new ideas and
thoughts about well how do we choose the
best topics and how do we manage the
boundaries between topics the topic
heuristic is very intuitive to the human
mind what we don't realize is that we're
making these micro decisions constantly
in our conversations to manage topics so
every literally every time you speak
you're choosing whether to stay on this
topic or switch to something else so I'm
trying to be a very polite podcast guest
and answer your question about structure
but I could Jag and start talking about
the Kardashians right like that's an
option that I have so that's topics
right topics chunk our turns into
thematic logical chunks and then even
still within this like mechanical bucket
we think a lot about what and you said
this nicely earlier what we talk about
there's actually a lot of more
complexity there than we might
intuitively realize there's actually
three streams of content the first is
verbal the words we say to each other
the second is non-verbal and that's
everything about how your body's moving
your hand just regulation your facial
expressions your eye gaze everything
that's not that you perceive visually
about other people is non-verbal then
there's this third bucket that a lot of
people don't know about or think about
as a separate category that's extremely
important for the structure of
conversations and that's paralanguage
and it's Everything acoustic about how
we're talking to each other that's not
words so words are the carriers of
meaning but apparel language also can
change the meaning if I say I love that
mat that's very different than I love
that Matt I love it it changes it
entirely and it's just an acoustic
property the tone of my voice how fast
I'm saying it the pausing whether I
laugh while I'm doing it and there's so
many aspects of paralinguish that that
can change
I want to come back to small talk
because small talk is something that
many of us struggle with the Chit Chat
that we have at mixers or at Coffee
meetings or or even cocktail parties can
be really challenging for people what
advice and guidance do you have to make
small talk less challenging and are
there certain choices you talked about
conversation being a series of choices
that we can make that can help Small
Talk go more smoothly yes so talk gets a
bad a bad rap man it's not Fair it gets
a really bad rep the purpose of small
talk is to help us coordinate easily
around more interesting topics right
this everything about conversation is
the sort of coordination kerfuffle we're
trying to coordinate with another human
mind like what should we be talking
about how should we be interacting what
do I feel safe sharing with you Etc
small talk is really useful it's the
predictable way that we open up this
really crazy experience we're about to
have together and so I think it gets too
bad a rap it serves a very important
sort of search process so if you think
of small talk as a search and really
lean into it as this like enjoyable
search process then it can become less
awkward I like that notion of reframing
for sure and I think that can help and
when you see it as a serving of purpose
Beyond just this awkward I'm standing
next to you and need to say something
I've come to learn and I'm curious if
you have other insights into this that
in small talk are just the decision
Visions we make can really influence how
the conversation goes and I've heard
that there are two choices people often
make either supporting choices of the
topic that's being discussed are
shifting choices do you have insight
into that and perhaps other types of
choices that we can make to make things
better or worse yeah so we studied topic
selection a lot and we call it topic
management two choices is actually a a
good heuristic but it's oversimplifying
what we're doing so what we how we study
this we study a topic selection on a
turn-by-turn basis so every time someone
talks they're making a micro decision
and you can imagine it as like I'm
staying on this topic I'm going to
support the topic or I'm going to switch
that's a good heuristic but actually
there's some gray area in between those
two poles right so there's also I'm
going to passively let you stay on this
topic versus I'm going to actively
encourage us to stay on this topic I'm
going to say oh my God that's amazing
tell me more
which is very different than like uh-huh
right like that's that's a big
difference and the same with switching
you can imagine moves that are very
subtly drifting
that are almost ambiguous like we're not
sure if we're moving on to a new topic
or if it's just a sort of like an
adjacent fuzzy drift away from the
current one and then there are really
aggressive switches to new ones where
we're talking about conversation with
each other and then I'm like and also
let me tell you about my chicken salad
sandwich wow so yummy everyone should
eat chicken salad there's like lots of
shades of when we're making these
choices about how to manage topics
there's like shades of things you can do
to support as you said or switch to to
something new we can all feel when a
topic like the juice is like dried up
from a topic what we find in our
research is that people who assertively
switch in those moments are a great
conversationalists right if you can
sense if there's longer pauses if
there's awkward laughter if people start
repeating things they've already said on
the topic it's their signals that it's
time to switch and so doing so
assertively is something we can all do a
little bit better we we have this
instinct to be a little afraid made to
switch topics because it feels rude or
abrupt or maybe they have more to say
when in fact it's much safer and usually
a good idea to switch to something new
because boredom and stagnation are
bigger risks than we know so I I'm not
going to take the advice you just gave
and and abruptly switch topics because
I'm hearing a theme across several of
the things you've talked about and it's
really about being sensitive to what's
needed in the moment and to me this
thoughtfulness this slowing down is
related really to listening you and I
study communication and there's this
notion that in communication it's about
what you're saying but so often I'm
coming to realize it's about what you're
listening and hearing and I know in a
recent chat you and I had you shared
with me that you're really beginning to
focus your research on listening and I'm
curious if you could share a little bit
about how you see listening and how we
can become better listeners it's so
funny that you say this map because my
my course is called talk and the great
irony of it is that I think it should
really be called listen like that's one
of the biggest takeaways from it is that
it's so hard to be a good listener and
so very important so we have some really
exciting research about listening that's
just come out I work on this topic with
a PhD student here at Harvard named
Hannah Collins and a co-author named
Mikey Omens and my colleague at the
Harvard Kennedy School named Julia
minson and what we've realized is
the human mind is built to wander it's
not built to focus in on one person for
long stretches of time and yet that's
what conversation demands of our mind is
to really pay attention to those three
streams of content that I mentioned
earlier the verbal content all those
non-verbal cues and also the
perilanguage it's like drinking from
fire hydrant right we're bombarded by
information and that information is very
interesting it often makes our minds
make connections to random ideas and
then we want to elaborate and think
about something else it's tremendous
work to stay focused on a conversation
partner as the whole conversation
unfolds and so what we have found in our
research is a key a key piece of this is
like if you're putting in the effort to
listen attentively to somebody
show it to them don't just assume that
they know and so there's decades and
Decades of work on active listening this
focuses on things like eye contact and
nodding and smiling and laughing at the
right times and leaning towards your
partner these sort of non-verbal cues
that you're listening to somebody and
that's all great but it's great as a
very basic starting point what we're
finding now is actually expressing your
attentive listening with your words is
what makes someone such a compelling
Communicator so I heard you earlier
talking that you also eat the same lunch
every day and be and the only way that I
can say that now is because I was
listening to you and so remembering to
bring it up later or Express affirmation
and say that's so interesting that you
eat the same lunch every day why do you
do that and asking a follow-up question
these are undeniable cues that you've
actually heard someone process what they
were saying and you're repeating it back
to them so these are the sort of High
Fidelity cues of good listening and
often people put in the work to listen
to someone and they just forget to show
it they forget to say it out loud and
it's a huge missed opportunity so the
ways to do this are through things like
follow-up questions callbacks to earlier
topics paraphrasing what someone has
said or if someone has said something
that's confusing again revisiting those
repair strategies like can you ask a
question that helps to fix a quick
misunderstanding or this sort of Rift in
your shared reality can you do it right
then and there like you say oh I heard
you say something about listening I
didn't quite understand can you explain
that a little bit more to me all of
these things show that you're listening
attentively to someone and that you care
I think the gift of listening is a true
gift and having to demonstrate it
through your words is really really
important and as somebody who hosts a
podcast and teaches people how to
interview and to run panels all the
skills that you just talked about are
critical in that success Matt are you
always caught in like the meta Loop do
you feel like you're floating over the
room watching yourself it's like teach
about because you're communicating about
communication meta communication is
really critical to becoming a better
communicator but I I absolutely agree
and I actually describe it just like you
did that to become a better Communicator
you have to be engaged in it and present
in the moment but at the same time
observing it from above to see what's
going on and what's needed in a really
effective communicators learn how to
toggle between those two areas of focus
to be effective and it takes practice
and time to do it
you know Alison this conversation has
been absolutely fantastic I have learned
a lot I'd love to ask you the same three
questions I ask everybody on this
podcast are you ready for that
I was born ready I'm sure I know that
for sure question one if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you have ever received as a five to
seven word presentation slide title what
would it be one thing that sticks with
me this was from a professional
Matchmaker named Rachel Greenwald who I
love and adore and who also teaches
communication she uses this catchphrase
be more interested than interesting
I think that's a really powerful bit of
advice especially going back to the
notion of small talk and chit chat it's
really not about you it's about them and
I love that idea about being interested
rather than interesting and
engine but to me conversation is just
the vehicle by which we sort of express
our Humanity to each other and are
caring for other people and so this idea
of being more interested in others than
trying to be interesting yourself is a
good nudge to move Beyond it's not about
you right it's about you have people
that surround you and what you're
building with them for sure I am going
to be really curious to hear your answer
to this one number two who is a
communicator you admire and why
it's such a great question there are so
many communicators I admire Matt I mean
I admire you as a communicator and for
many reasons perhaps the most
embarrassing one is because you have
such a lovely Timbre to your voice it's
it's like Pleasant to hear all the time
why thank you my yes we should get you
to sing on this on this podcast no that
would be a disaster I think my real
answer here is Stephen Colbert in my
course we watch a few examples of his
live conversation with other people the
first one is a conversation he has with
uh comedian Ricky Gervais and they're
talking they're debating the existence
of God have you seen this conversation I
have not so Ricky Gervais has trained as
a philosopher and what I love about it
is that it's a super serious topic and
yet they find these moments of levity
that are just so amazing
and even beyond the levity they show
incredible graciousness to the other
person's perspective wonderful question
number three what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe this is so hard
it's so hard to pick as a scientist I
can tell you what the most robust
predictors are of a good conversation
it's hard to narrow it down to three I
think it comes down to choosing good
topics and making any topic good asking
good questions finding moments of levity
and expressing our kindness to other
people but that's an easy answer so
that's not gonna be my answer my real
answer I talk about this I have a book
coming out next year and so in the book
we talk about minding the Gap Gap
so Gap are these three ingredients of
gratitude so being grateful for your
conversation partners and even giving
you the time the honor of their time and
to be in their presence the a is
acceptance so every great conversation
starts from a place of acceptance it's
sort of this Mantra of yes and that we
borrow from stand-up comedians and then
the p is patience so knowing that we're
always going to make mistakes being
patient with ourselves and with other
people and trying to fix them well I
cannot wait for your book to come out
and I really appreciate you filling in
those gaps for us today and helping us
understand better how we can communicate
and Converse and really listen so that
we can engage demonstrate warmth and
learn from others Allison this was a
tremendous pleasure to have you on and
it was great to chat with you I'm so
grateful for your time thanks Matt
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
this episode was produced by Jenny Luna
Michael Riley and me Matt Abrahams our
theme music is composed by Floyd wander
we invite you to find more episodes
wherever you get your podcasts
be sure to tell a friend or two to
listen in as well subscribe and go ahead
and rate and review the show as well
finally join us on LinkedIn where our
conversation continues
foreign